This story begins before Christmas was a thought.
The story is happy, the beginning is not.
That night, we got reports that there was a forest fire...
...fairly close to town.
I looked out my office window and I saw what was an orange glow.
From the driveway, you could see Wildwood Estates was on fire...
...and all of the hills were on fire.
So, you were just driving in the fire.
The town needed to know that while things may seem rotten,...
...this too shall pass.
They have not been forgotten.
There was food,...
...there was song,...
...so they could all smile and dance.
Christmas could still be merry, it just needed a chance.
The crowd was amazed,...
...a surprise from above!
Special gifts in the sky,...
...tiny boxes of love.
Each gift was a keepsake to remember the night...
...and everyone in every family also got a free flight.